all right for my talk of the table I am
looking ahead to my 48 Hours report this
weekend when Cassandra Cantrell vanished
in the summer of 2020 her friends and
family had no idea where she had gone
and then investigators discovered
surveillance video of a mysterious man
in a hat leaving her car 48 Hours
obtained that never before seen footage
here's a preview of my report
on August 26 2020 33 year old Cassandra
Cantrell was supposed to meet her best
friend Alexandra McNary but she never
showed up I texted her hey where are you
I got no response I left panicked
messages until her voicemail box was
full Cassandra had vanished 2 Days Later
police found her car in an industrial
area near downtown Tacoma but why was it
there Pierce County Sheriff's detective
Franz helmke knew the city's light rail
system was nearby and discovered they
had footage of Cassandra's car we're
able to see the white car Cassandra's
Cassandra's car you can see a subject
getting out of the vehicle and start
walking away you can see him walking
across the street he's dressed in all
black black shoes black pants black
T-shirt blue surgical gloves and a black
fedora who was the man in the Hat helke
believed he was the key to finding
Cassandra he knew something he was
involved Alexandra says when she saw the
video she immediately knew who it was
Colin Dudley Cassandra met him in 2006.
was he always wearing a hat he would put
it on and switch into his Persona of the
hatman and preferred to be called The
Hat Man helmke confronted Colin but
Colin insisted he hadn't seen Cassandra
in years their conversation was recorded
do you have any contact with no messages
or no Facebook or anything no humpke
suspected Colin was lying and there was
something else about Cassandra she was
Keeping a Secret which was unusual for
her yeah turned out to be a Deadly
Secret yes yeah it did
[Music]
so what did surveillance cameras the
role what did they what they play in
this well as you saw there was
incredible surveillance footage again
this was the very first time we were
able to see the police released it to us
exclusively and what's fascinating it's
not just the surveillance video this
this case really broke because of the
digital footprint that we all create of
course we know there are cameras
everywhere your cell phones you can
track them everywhere but also what
broke this case wide open was tracking
that man hatman his name is Colin Dudley
his car in your car people may not
realize is you actually have you know
the equivalent of a black box which is
but they have on airplanes yeah that
Reveal Your locations and where you
travel and that pretty much gave away
the rest of the story so so can you tell
us what that secret is or should we wait
and see the episode you're gonna have to
watch and see I will say that that man
you saw there
um definitely had a past with Cassandra
and they had reconnected but I'm not
going to say much more about okay I was
on the edge of my seat yes but that said
he was living with another woman had a
whole other life so
um and he said he had no relationship
with this woman to the police but you'll
see there are some things that are
different yeah for sure you can see my
full report Cassandra's secret on 48
hours that's tomorrow night at 10 9
Central right here on CBS and on
Paramount plus we're